the stork is on the way we'll see how it
trickles down
[Music]
you would be close three you would be
safe to bet on three in 2022 yeah one
month later nick cannon's prediction is
coming true
[Music]
the comedian is expecting his 10th child
this one with brittany bell
she and nick already have two kids
together five-year-old son golden and
one-year-old daughter powerful queen
[Music]
brittany breaking the baby news with a
stunning maternity shoot i just say i
like i love children i want to
try to document everything like that and
the family runs through a marathon of
ideas
rocking chairs picnics and a flower
power moment to name just a few
[Music]
yeah nick's got plenty to celebrate this
year this announcement comes just one
month after he welcomed his eighth child
legendary love his first kid with bree
tac let me see
just let me see
hey
legendary i also notice over here you
have the library already lots of reading
to do right lots of reading and then
legendary love yes
yes i think it's just you know plays
into our relationship so
i loved that
yeah and about nick's prediction you
would be cool three you would be safe to
bet on three in 2022. legendary love was
won
his and britney's next bundle of joy is
two
and abby de la rosa's bun in the oven
will make three
she and nick already parents to 11 month
old twins zion and zillion the stork is
on the way
of course nyx also bothered to 11 year
old twins monroe and moroccan with
ex-wife mariah carey and as he tells it
making time for all his kids comes easy
it's not as difficult as people think it
would be but i understand because it's a
very unorthodox scenario but it actually
i mean i dedicate probably
my entire day to my children luckily
we're in a world where
my life and i think i might have said
this and was misquoted before but i was
like i get i'm blessed with the
opportunity i get to spend more time
with my children every single day
because of my world and my business
[Music]
you